also die allergrößte Panne war
sicherlich erstmal dass Leute die wählen
wollten nicht wählen konnten ja weil ja
bekanntermaßen teilweise drei Stunden
die Menschen in den Schlangen standen
aushalten mussten gerade auch ältere
Familien mit Kindern wieder weggehen
muss noch mal wieder kam und dann
erfahren haben auch Mensch jetzt sind
keine Stimmzettel mehr da jetzt kannst
du auch nicht mehr wählen das war ein
ganz dramatisches Problem ein weiteres
war das falsche Stimmzettel ausgegeben
worden vorsätzlich teilweise wir haben
es in Friedrichshain Kreuzberg gehabt
das von den Grünen geführte Wahlamt hat
gezielt falsche Stimmzettel ausgeben
lassen und den Leuten dann gesagt er tut
uns leid habt ihr halt leider ungültig
gewählt wir haben sogenannte Friedhof
Stimmen gehabt das heißt bereits
verstorbene bekommen eine
Wahlbenachrichtigung zugeschickt der
Erbe was auch immer vielleicht auch der
Hinterblieben wäre auch immer öffnet die
Post kann das grundsätzlich ausfüllen
zurückschicken weil du mich niemand die
Unterschriften vergleichen und dann
werden Briefwahlunterlagen rausgeschickt
auch etwa 20.000 und wir haben die
Situation gehabt dass Menschen Briefwahl
Bean gesagt haben dadurch werden sie
automatisch im Wählerverzeichnis für die
Urnenwahl gesperrt gehen dann los
stellen fest ach Mensch ich habe leider
immer noch gar keine Post bekommen kann
gar nicht die Briefwahl machen wollen im
Wahllokal wählen und sind dort dann
ebenfalls sehr gesperrt können also gar
nicht wählen das betraf etwa 80 bis
90.000 stimmen also die ungültig
ausgegeben und dementsprechend auch
nicht ungültig eingesetzt werden konnten
und ähnlich erleben wir das jetzt gerade
zumindest in Teilen auch bereits wieder
wir haben das große Thema des
Poststreiks hier in Berlin hier gerade
und ausgerechnet jetzt wo also die Wahl
bevorsteht wo Briefwahlunterlagen
unterwegs sind wird Berlin sowieso schon
eine lange Postleitzahl hat auch noch
zusätzlich bestreitet also insofern
können wir hier erwarten dass das Chaos
nicht viel geringer sein wird fürchte
ich bin mir sicher dass es an den Ohren
besser laufen wird aber insgesamt muss
ich sagen trifft auch diese Vorbereitung
nicht ansatzweise dass wir eigentlich
Wahlen organisiert sein sollten haben
sie jetzt auch erlebt ist ein teilweise
Kandidaten auf den Stimmzetteln
aufgetauch den ich drauf gehörten es
sind Kandidaten von den Stimmzetteln
gestrichen worden die tatsächlich noch
keine dieren und wir haben jetzt die
absurde Situation dass Leute die die
Parteien gewechselt haben wir haben es
irgendwo bei einem Wechsel von den
Linken zu den Grünen immer noch auf der
Liste der einen Partei stehen für die
auch gewählt werden ganz automatisch und
dann aber der anderen Fraktion im
Parlament angegangen also am Sonntag und
ist eventuell wieder für die Katze
vielleicht noch mal verschieben müssen
oder Hoffnung das habe ich für sehr sehr
richtig gehalten und habe genau das auch
tatsächlicher beantragt beim
landesverfassungsgerichtshof dem ist man
zunächst nicht gefolgt wer mir die
Situation des gleichzeitig jetzt
Kollegen aus FDP linken SPD und Grünen
diese Anfechtung quasi wieder
angefochten haben das liegt jetzt beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht so dass es also
durchaus sein kann dass wir in einigen
Wochen erfahren werden Edge das was am
12.02 stattgefunden hat war doch keine
Wahl durfte nicht stattfinden das geht
wieder das alte Ergebnis in dem Fall
gehe ich allerdings auch dagegen wird
davor dann gibt's noch den Europäischen
Gerichtshof der darüber entscheiden
müsste also es ist unfassbares Chaos und
bitte Aufklärung des Chaos so
dilettantisch wie das hier leider
gelaufen ist auch von Berliner
landesverfassungsgerichtshof das muss
ich an der Stelle mal sagen der
überfield ist einfach leider
hinweggegangen ist was vorgetragen wurde
sind wir jetzt in der Situation dass wir
das Vertrauen in die Demokratie meines
Erachtens eher noch mehr beschädigt
haben als das was ausgeholt hätten Herr
Karl wenn Sie das hören was funktioniert
überhaupt noch wir hatten gestern hier
pETER HAHN in der Sendung der sagte hier
ganz klar es ist aus seiner sich nicht
mehr viel also von der Bahn bis zur
Bundeswehr was funktioniert eigentlich
noch in Deutschland und jetzt sind wir
hier die Befürchtung für den Sonntag
also wie funktioniert nicht mehr aber
ich glaube bevor ich zu der Frage kommen
vielleicht nur eins zwei Sätze zu der
Wahl selbst erstmal denke ich dass wir
alle anlutet danken sollten dass er das
überhaupt auf den Weg gebracht hat denn
ohne Wahlen gibt es keine Demokratie
also Demokratie besteht nicht nur aus
Wahlen aber ohne Wahlen gibt es keine
und ich glaube dass die ganz weit
überwiegende Mehrheit der Menschen in
diesem Land die Demokratie möchte und
wenn wir die möchten dann müssen wir ein
bisschen Mühe uns geben und da reicht es
nicht wenn wir sagen sagen ich kann es
halt ja sondern wir machen doch diesen
ganzen Unsinn nach der Devise wir können
es ja wir können uns ja erlauben wir
können uns ja leisten es können wir aber
eben genau nicht und dass die Wahlen in
Berlin nicht funktionieren das ist
eigentlich nur ein Symptom Berlin ist
generell ich sag mal typischerweise der
Negativentwicklung die Deutschland als
Land insgesamt leider nimmt und genommen
hat immer ein paar Jahre voraus es hat
die Hauptstadt zu an sich deswegen ist
das spotten über Berlin zwar wohl fein
und ich habe es auch selber schon
verbrochen aber es ist im Grunde
genommen auch mit einem Blick in den
Spiegel für den Rest des Landes und so
viel funktioniert in der Tat nicht mehr
Herrn hat sehr schön formuliert ist
Bundeswehr ist ich sag mal so zum Thema
Abwehrbereitschaft gegen äußere gefahren
habe ich mal den Scherz gemacht wir
können froh sein das Lichtenstein gerade
nicht einmarschieren will ja ähm oder ob
es die Wirtschaft ist die ich sag mal an
allen Ecken und Enden vor die Wand
gedrückt wird aber da kommen wir nachher
noch drauf
oder ob es unseren unsere
Abstimmungsprozesse im internation
normalen Umfeld sind das im Grunde
genommen jedes Steinchen dass man hier
umdreht da sitzt ein hässliches Tierchen
drunter hat man immer das Gefühl und da
fragt man sich natürlich schon woran
liegt nach meiner Meinung liegt daran
dass wir eine Negativauswahl unserer
politischen Klasse haben darf ich eine
Frage stellen ja
Blödheit oder es ist Bosheit dass das
nicht funktioniert hat
also ich habe dazu oder also zu dem
Gesamtkomplex im Buch geschrieben mit
dem schönen Untertitel also über Berlin
unsere Hauptstadt ist ein Missmanagement
und organisierter Kriminalität und
insofern das beantwortet ist eigentlich
es ist ein breites spektakulär sie haben
einerseits das und zum anderen das und
es kann eben die von Ihnen als Bosheit
bezeichnete Eigenschaft dann natürlich
noch mal besonders gedeihen wenn Sie
zusätzlich auf Dummheit trifft und
wechselseitig und insofern haben wir
hier glaube ich in der Tat eine eine
fatale Entwicklung die sich
wechselseitig bedingt und das wird eben
an keiner Stelle durchgegriffenes Ende
wie ist das für sie Blick aus dem
Ausland aus Österreich wenn Sie das
Hören diese Aufzählung was alles schief
lief bei der ersten Wahl die Befürchtung
dass es vielleicht am Sonntag wieder zu
peinlichsten Pannen kommen könnte was
denkt man darüber Deutschland
von Berliner Flughafen der das war ja
offensichtlich auch ein riesiges
disaster ich meine wir sind jetzt auch
nicht ohne in Wien geht's auch ab muss
man sagen aber wahrscheinlich nicht auf
dem Niveau oder
blicken sie da auf Deutschland
ich mache mir halt als Psychiater jetzt
Gedanken dieses Bosheit ist es korrupt
also werden wir immer korrupter oder
oder wenn wir mal blöder weil ich weiß
nicht ob sowas in den 50er 60er 70er
Jahren auch passieren hätte können und
da habe ich natürlich meine These von
den Bauchgefühlen ich glaube dass wir
unsere Bau also dass wir viel zu viel
fühlen und viel zu wenig denken also das
glaube ich ist ein Grundproblem in
unserer Gesellschaft immer mehr also die
Leute kommen zu mir und sagen es fühlt
sich wahr an und dann sage ich immer
aber da müssen sie nachdenken ob es wahr
ist aber nicht so schön
wir werden auch blöder
also das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich von
Ihnen hören aber ich würde nein also wir
sind blöd wenn wir nur mit dem
bauchdenken dann sind wir blöd also wir
sind ein wir sind Menschen also Simon
freut redet von Prinz tanzen ich habe
das sozusagen umgearbeitet auf Kopf Herz
und Bauch wir haben Bauchgefühle die
sind wichtig aber das sind in sich sagen
wir mal nicht die intelligente aber dann
brauchen wir den Kopf der denkt darüber
nach was der Bauch sagt und das Herz
entscheidet aber wenn wir aus dem Bauch
heraus entscheiden dann sind wir